welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital music
part one the science of sound
and recording before we can look at how
music and sounds are
stored on the computer we need to review
how
sounds are actually generated and how
recording actually occurs
start off by assuming that we're in our
classroom and the stanford symphony
orchestra is playing
beethoven's fifth symphony out in front
of the class
now what happens when they're playing
the symphony
what's happening is the various
instruments are generating sound waves
and those sound waves travel through the
air
and they reach our eardrums and so what
we perceive
as music is the sound waves hitting our
eardrums
now suppose we want to send the stanford
symphony orchestra home
and listen to a recording of them
instead well what we're going to do is
we're going to start off same as we did
before
with the stanford symphony orchestra
playing live and then we're going to
replace our ears
with some microphones we have a single
microphone we placed in the middle of
the room
that microphone picks up the sound waves
as they hit the microphone
and somehow we need to store the sound
wave that is generated
using that microphone we could start on
something like a magnetic tape for
example
we can start on an old school phonograph
you know somehow we need to
store the amplitude and frequency of the
wave
that the symphony orchestra is playing
now in the case of stereo
we're going to set up two microphones
one on the left and one on the right
and we're going to do the same thing the
sound waves will reach
the microphones at slightly different
times
we go ahead and take again the magnitude
and frequency of the sound wave and we
go ahead and record it
now what we're going to do is we send
the stanford symphony orchestra home
we get some speakers and we hook them up
to our recordings
and if the speakers are able to generate
the exact same
sound waves that the stanford symphony
orchestra originally created
we basically have a complete
reproduction of the stanford symphony
orchestra's performance
we can actually take a look at what
these sound waves look like
using some tools that are available on
the computer what we're going to do next
is we're going to take a look at a
program called audacity which is going
to let us
take a look at these sound waves i'm
going to play a version of
beethoven's fifth symphony and i'm gonna
use the microphone on my computer to
pick up
the sound of the symphony orchestra
playing and what we're gonna see is
audacity is going to
show us the way sound waves as the music
plays
if we take the wave that we've been
watching here on audacity and we blow it
up
we're gonna see this and we blow it up
even more
this is what it looks like and so our
next task is to take this wave that
we're looking at right here
and somehow convert it into
bits and bytes so we can start in the
computer